y 500 rondas de bombardeos en 40 minutos
por tierra y aire el ejército de israel
lanzó una intensa ofensiva sobre la
franja de gaza- la mayor operación desde
la nueva escalada de tensiones
el primer ministro israelí ya lo había
advertido dije que le haría pagar un
alto precio a hamás y otras
organizaciones terroristas continuaremos
con esta operación el tiempo que haga
falta para restaurar la paz y
tranquilidad del estado de israel
los ataques destruyeron edificios y se
cobraron más víctimas mortales entre los
palestinos la cifra ya supera el
centenar
esta familia solo pudo alcanzar el
refugio de una escuela de las naciones
unidas cuando los bombardeos se dieron
por víctor planeábamos signos por la
noche pero los drones y aviones no
dejaban de bombardearnos cuando nos
despertamos encontramos todo destruido
no queda nada
lejos de atenuarse las tensiones siguen
aumentando las tropas de israelíes se
agrupan en la frontera en la madrugada
del viernes el ejército anunció su
entrada en la franja de gaza- para luego
desmentir lo un movimiento que podría
llegar en cualquier momento
las milicias palestinas mantienen sus
ataques aéreos la última noche
dispararon 50 misiles contra israel
además dos misiles más fueron lanzados
desde el sur de líbano un ataque sin
autoría clara y los esfuerzos de
mediación de la delegación egipcia que
viajó hasta tel aviv no dieron frutos
los mediadores ya dejaron israel
convencidos de que el gobierno rechaza
cualquier posibilidad de alto al fuego
el domingo el consejo de seguridad de la
onu se reunirá para discutir la
situación en la región